Thank you for convening this
hearing and for considering
my nomination.
Let's move on, I want to go to the
child porn.
Hello, everyone, sorry, I'm on Zoom,
I'm sure, you know why.
No it's not COVID, I just don't want
to be in the same room as Ted Cruz
and Sheldon Whitehouse.
We're here to carry out one of this
committee's most solemn
constitutional obligations.
Engaging in the politics of personal
destruction.
Sounds about right.
Judge Jackson's nomination,
of course, is historic.
If you were confirmed, you
would be the first ever...
I know where this is going.
F.
Federal public defender to sit on
the court.
Oh, cool.
Nice to have someone with experience
fighting the government for once.
We're off to a very good start.
This will not be a political circus.
I have no reason to believe that.
Seems like a pretty good judge to
me.
I do think all of my
colleagues in advance for being
respectful, thoughtful
and and open minded.
You might have pulled the trigger
a little early on that.
We don't do that with people who
come to Congress.
This is often a staging ground for
nasty, evidence free personal
attacks.
That was a lie.
You're some kind of commie fascist
Nazi terrorist child porn guy am
I doing it right?
Why are some people so mean?
This will not be the kind
of character smear
that sadly our Democratic colleagues
have gotten very good at.
Isn't that a character smear?
Democrats interrupted me for
more than an hour during my opening
statement on the Kavanaugh hearing.
You guys are still talking about
Kavanaugh.
We started down this road of
character assassination in the 1980s
with Judge Bork's hearings.
Seriously, he said, Bork, I got
bingo! I got bingo!
Where you nerd out with me
a little bit?
Dungeons and Dragons? I can do that.
It's just it's a fun, role playing
game.
Do not untie me no matter how much
I beg or.
Mike, that's a different kind of
role play.
You want me to go first?
I'm good.
Everybody still got their character
sheets.
Well, it's fine. You can just make
new ones.
You can you can make up a new
character where you can start fresh.
I could make myself the hero.
More of a bard.
I was a little insulted.
Who did? Who do you want to be?
Abraham Lincoln.
Trump.
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
Odysseus.
Ruby Bridges.
Super duper
president.
The Black Woman.
I, maybe this was
a bad idea.
They can choose their gender.
I find that bizarre.
Look, you can be whatever character
you want. You just have to remember
to put down the attributes.
Strength.
Intelligence.
Intelligence and wisdom.
Now, I don't understand the
difference.
Intelligence is being smart and
wisdom is not wanting
to be in Congress.
All of that goes
into forming who
you are.
Could could I decide I was an Asian
man?
Not if you want to go to Harvard.
There are three dusty doors
in front of you.
Let us commit ourselves
to do our part to open these
doors.
Who decides?
You all decide together.
It's a cooperative game.
God bless America.
We don't do that much stuff
bipartisan round here.
You're not really going to go through
the door without checking for traps
fIrst are you?
Your worst enemies
could be behind that door.
Like America.
Uh..
The 1619 project.
Nazis and Russians and Prussians
and Hapsburgs.
Sure?
They will crush you.
They will attack you.
They will slander you.
They will filibuster.
Wait, what?
Poison Dart hits Coons.
I've been struck.
You've had a lot of poison thrown at
you.
He was ambushed.
20.
As critical.
Critical race theory.
What?
It is filled and overflowing
with critical race theory.
All right. You know what?
Just forget it.
Everyone died.
Not a surprise, but
perhaps a little bit of a
disappointment.
Yeah, kind of like congressional
hearings.
So now back to our business.
What constrains a judge is a judge
who is willing to be constrained.
That's why we have safe words.
There's no reason to think that you
are a pedophile.
That's the closest Josh Hawley has
to a compliment.
Does anyone enjoy this?
I don't. And I bet a lot of normal
Americans don't, either.
Thank you for separating yourself
from normal America.
Drug overdose deaths and gang
crime have both skyrocketed in
recent years.
Lindsey was in a gang MS 13.
14. Whatever gang I was in, I've
been in so many. I can't remember.
Crips as they were known when we
were in law school.
Don't mess with Lindsay.
Bullying.
Beat the crap out of the guy
First thing you do when you get in
congress is find the biggest,
baddest congressman you can and beat
the crap out of him.
So the other ones respect you.
I've seen it happen.
We have a justice system that treats
you better if you're rich and guilty
than if you're poor and innocent.
Is that why all of you were so calm?
I just feel this sense of
overwhelming joy.
Feel like you're one of the emotions
in that movie "Inside Out.".
I've seen the good, the
bad and the ugly,.
Sass, Ted Cruz
and Ted Cruz agai?
What is a fundamental right.
You should know that.
The founders established three
separate branches of our government.
She is a judge.
She knows that.
What's your hidden agenda?
You know, standard lizard people
stuff.
Is it to let violent criminals,
cop killers and child predators back
to the streets?
That explains why she's been
twirling her mustache the entire
hearing.
Here is the problem.
Agreed!
Here.
Right here is the problem.
Educators are allowing biological
males to steal opportunities
from female athletes.
What is wrong with your hair?
She wasn't groomed.
44 percent of Americans now
disapprove of the Supreme Court.
Congress dreams of having a
disapproval rating that low.
You and I have known each other a
long time.
I know that I'm not comfortable. It's
not an opinion
that I think
is appropriate for me to
share.
We have a saying in New Jersey.
Breathe through your mouth?
Don't mess with the sanitation
department?
People are too dumb to pump their
own gas.
What we really need is a good
reality television show about
shirtless people on a beach.
All hat, no cattle.
All hat, no..In
Jersey?
The American public is now tuning
into these proceedings, expecting a
substantive discussion.
Oh, you're the new guy.
How do we feel it went today?
One of the lowest moments in the
history of this committee.
I could not stop being just joyous.
I did my best. Is that what you did?
Honestly, no. I kind of phoned this
one in.
And I think it's been long
overdue.
Yeah, they probably should have come
out last Friday.
I think we have to accept some
responsibility for that, senator.
Portions of this were used out of
context,.
Guilty as charged.
I hope I get a very lenient
sentence.
Good flourish at the end.